لم تره في عشرات السنين
حدث في سنه واحده
[موسيقى]
في مركز محافظه سيدي بوزيد
تخلى الرئيس التونسي زين العابدين بن علي
عن السلطان بمقتضى التسويه ممارسه سلطات
رئيس الجمهوري كيف تستقبلون تخلي بنعلي عن
السلطه
يعني الاجواء متوتره في ميدان التحرير
اعلن الرئيس المصري محمد حسني مبارك عن
تفويض نائبه عمر سليمان بصلاحياته
ان دماء شهداء وجرح الاحداث التي شهدتها
مصر مؤخرا لن تضيع هدرا
الرئيس اليمني يعلن حاله الطوارئ في
البلاد ترمقتل اكثر من اربعين محتجا في
صنعاء
[موسيقى]
ففجرت ميليشيا الحوثي منزل الرئيس اليمني
السابق علي عبد الله صالح
لنرى الفيديو الذي نشره الاوطيون وهم
يقتلون صالح
الثقه من الجنوب بحكمه
[موسيقى]
بمقتل القذافي ينتهي حكمه لليبيا الذي
استمر نحو 42 عاما قبل ان يسقطه الثوار
ليهرب الى سرد حيث قتل هذا اليوم
[موسيقى]
قوات الامن السوريه فرق التظاهره امام
المسجد الاموي في دمشق
التظاهرات المطالبه بالحريه في سوريا تتسع
لتشمل دمشق واللاذقيه وحمص وحماه الاخبار
المتواتره كثيره جدا
تتحمل قصه كبير عن الجرائم التي تجري في
سوريا
في قلب سوريا نصفين بالغازات السامه على
عين [__] وزمالكا وجوبر يا
الله مجزره كيماويه مربعه
[تصفيق]
الجهاز الامن والمخابرات السودانيه في
بيان له انه يؤيد حق التظاهر السلبي
وفضل حاله الطوارئ في جميع مناطق الولايه
المسلحه المنتشره في كل مواقع الان
[موسيقى]
الجيش عزل البشير واعتقله في مكان امن